amazon CEO jeff bezos speaking to
Charlie Rhodes on 60 minutes last night
you should absolutely with something
called the octocopter it's a drone that
Amazon is testing to deliver your latest
book or your latest iPad take listen let
me show you something oh man oh my god
this this is these are octocopters yeah
these are effectively drones but there's
no reason that they can't be used as
delivery vehicles take a look up here so
I can show you how it works we're
talking about delivery here we're
talking about deliveries so there's an
item going into the vehicle
I know this looks like science fiction
it's not wow this is early this is still
years away drops the package there's the
package come and get your package and we
can do half hour delivery half hour
deliver half hour delivery and we can
carry objects we think up to five pounds
which covers eighty six percent of the
items that we deliver I'm sorry the
pheasant hunters in the field and I
think of poll seriously I I know
someone's going to run over it in my
driveway or on the street it's a gift
for burglars who want to steal stuff too
this certainly make the balcony in New
York City more valuable than that
something get it to your balcony that's
the other big question in fact last year
amazon sold more than 26 million items
on Cyber Monday it is Cyber Monday don't
forget so maybe in five years this will
be a reality on Cyber Monday but we do
want to add a programming note here Cory
Johnson will be live inside Amazon's
phoenix area fulfillment center later
today he's going to bring you an inside
look at amazon's cyber monday operation
it's great I mean they talk about
technological progress who would have
thought that that's great it's jeff
bezos wanting to channel google i just
wants to be cool this is one does about
cuz it's like five years away right away
get real it'll proving its research